re re
Bach Shibayama's army has swelled up a lot and revived
Hey, what is Shibayama, the play is going to work?
Hey,
eh,
tan
tee, I can't stand losing to the
bottom and the 4th floor
car
oo I'm not going to do it I
know because I know you must have been hit by a waterfall I was
watching the whole story of that time  Shibayama, who was about to be hit by the waterfall in the middle of the night, was pushed down from behind, and
after that you were the only one who was hit by the waterfall, right
?
Skaloke I like the conference world you created Let's make this town more fun from me
However, Shibayama was the only one who didn't go back, and
Kitagawa also disappeared later.
Rumor has it that he was looking for a certain amount of
money.
He must have made some strange discoveries at his new school
[music]